[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing an aspect
of the entire harry potter series honing
in on harry potter specifically
now there are a lot of unique notable
aspects about harry potter's character
his phoenix feather wand his eyes and of
course
his famous lightning bolt shaped
as of late however i've seen a
particularly large number of memes and
references
to another notable harry potter
characteristic his
glasses the memes in question
essentially declaring this
harry potter is the only student at
hogwarts
that wears glasses now it'd be safe to
state that harry is the only student in
the series
with a lightning bolt shaped scar but
glasses
surely someone else wears glasses right
i'm here to put this meme to bed first
things first
what makes this idea particularly hard
to believe is that
in the wizarding world eyesight is not
fixable
this statement is reinforced by the many
adult witches and wizards in the series
that wear glasses as well as all of
these references
to said glasses albus dumbledore half
moon exactly said dumbledore looking
very seriously over the top of his half
moon glasses
minerva mcgonagall square instead he was
smiling at a rather severe looking woman
who was wearing square glasses exactly
the shape of the markings the cat
had around its eyes and a myriad of
others
including amelia bones borgin aberforth
dumbledore
mafalda hopkirk bob ogden rufus krimger
rita skeeter sibel troloni arthur
weasley
etc the first thing worth mentioning is
that the answer to this question will
vary from book to film
in the films a lot of characters that
were supposed to wear glasses
aren't wearing them and you'll also find
that a lot of characters who don't wear
glasses
are wearing them let me start with three
perfect examples of hogwarts students
from the books that wear glasses
number one percy weasley i
don't want said percy thickly as the
twins forced the sweater over his head
knocking his glasses askew number two
myrtle i'd hidden because olive hornby
was teasing me about my glasses
number three james potter harry
recognized his father
his untidy black hair stuck up at the
back like harry's
and he too wore glasses now let's look
at the countless examples of students
wearing glasses in the films
[Music]
i rest my case and that's it for this
video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe
to the channel until next time it does
not do to dwell on dreams
and forget to live
you